uh souls of black folk by w.b
du bois uh was absolutely pivotal
pivotal in my intellectual development
uh
one of the uh premier
set of essays in the western literary
tradition
and it's a deep and profound
sociological
uh philosophical uh and historical
analysis of the uh predicament
of blacks in america from um
one of our country's greatest polymaths
uh it
it's just a it's a beautiful text and uh
and i go to it
uh yearly um so for somebody like me
so growing up in the soviet union the
struggle the civil rights movement the
struggle of race and all those kinds of
things
uh that that is you know this universal
but it's also very much
a journey of the united states it was
kind of a foreign thing that i stepped
into
um is that something you would recommend
somebody like me to read
or is there other uh things about race
that are good to connect because my my
my flavor of suffering and just i'm a
jew as well
my flavor has to do with world war two
and the studies of that
you know all the injustice is there so
i'm now stepping into a new set of
injustices
and trying to learn the the landscape
i would i would say anyone
is is a better person for having read
du bois it's just uh he's just a
remarkable
writer uh and thinker and it uh
i mean and to the extent you're
interested in learning another history
he does it in a way
that is uh quite sophisticated so it's a
you